I became involved with the conservation
work and,
uh,
through that,
um,
Dr Wilson's Biodiversity Foundation,
which aren't,
I'm on the board of,
because it was clear to me that,
uh,
that,
mankind,
human activity was degrading our earth's
resources at an alarmingly rapid rate
and that we were losing species,
um,
right and left important species
perhaps.
Uh,
in some cases we knew in other cases we
hadn't yet,
um,
full knowledge of a species or an
organism before it was lost.
It's my understanding that that much of
a much of our medicine,
much of our food stuff that may be
required in the,
in the future will come from these
reserves of biodiversity,
which are rapidly disappearing.
Um,
and unless we have a fully,
um,
uh,
protected,
bio,
uh,
systems,
we will not,
we'll lose the potential to learn how
nature works.
And that information may be critical in
our understanding of how to manipulate,
uh,
um,
what is in our power to manipulate to,
to save biodiversity,
save,
uh,
the power of our,
the
planet to sustain life.